hi in this video we are going to talk
about the regulation of glycolytic
pathway as we have already learned that
glycolysis is a ten step enzymatic
process where glucose is converted to
pyruvate and in this process ATP is
generated along with NADH which is
subsequently used in other metabolic
pathways so the starting point of
glycolysis is glucose from glucose
several intermediates such as glucose
6-phosphate glyceraldehyde 3 phosphates
are generated ultimately pyruvate is
formed and followed by production of
nadh and ATP that pyruvate can be
channeled inside the mitochondrion
format of acetyl-coa which can be
utilized in Krebs cycle and followed by
an electron transport chain to generate
more ATP so this whole process of using
glucose and channeling it into
glycolysis kreb cycle and electron
transport system ensures us that we have
enough amount of ATP for other metabolic
and biological processes inside a cell
let's imagine a situation where we have
too much ATP at this at a particular
time now in this situation when we
already have a lot of ADP making further
ATP would be a wasteful process right
and that is the beauty of our metabolic
pathways in this kind of circumstances
body has alternative ways by which it
can channel the intermediates of the
glycolytic pathway such as glucose
6-phosphate
which can be channeled into pentose
phosphate pathway for production of
reducing equivalent such as NADPH and
these reducing equivalents can be used
for any oxidoreductase type of a
reaction now
glucose 6-phosphate can also be
channeled for production of glycogen via
the process of glycogenesis and the
glycogen production takes place in liver
and muscles where it is stored it's like
a fixed deposit of glucose so we can
clearly understand this in step
enzymatic process of glycolysis is
highly highly regulated
totally dependent upon the energy demand
so let's look at how depending upon the
energy situation and nutrient
availability this pot process is
regulated so first of all this process
is highly regulated by allosteric
modulation of several glycolytic enzymes
now all of these enzymes of glycolytic
pathway are not under allosteric
modulation but key enzymes such as
hexokinase phosphofructokinase and
pyruvate kinase are under the control of
aldosterone is illustrating modulators
now let's look at what are the
allosteric modulator of these enzymes so
let us assume a situation where ATP is
high in this situation we don't need any
more glycolytic flux we need the flux to
be deviated towards other pathways such
as pentose phosphate pathway or
glycogenesis so we want to stop the
reaction how we would do that like the
body does it by modulating the level of
the modulating pyruvate kinase and
phosphofructokinase activity so ATP
concentration work like an allosteric
modulator and increase in ATP
concentration prevent
phosphofructokinase and pyruvate kinase
you can clearly understand from this
pathway if these two enzymes are
inhibited their activity is inhibited
the glycolysis won't take place so the
glycolytic flux would be deviated to
other pathways on the other hand if amp
level is high that means ATP is low and
the bodies under energy demand and body
needs energy in this situation MP
concentration works like an allosteric
activator of phosphofructokinase and
pyruvate kinase in this situation the
flux would flow through the glycolytic
pathway and the glycolytic pathway would
ensure ATP would be generated and
ultimately lot of energy can be
generated using this glycolytic pathway
now there are other substances such as
acetyl coa and site you guessing which
are actually part of the krebs cycle so
if these substances are already present
so
politic pathway is already not required
because there are alternative sources of
acetyl co a and cyclic acid so Krebs
cycle can work on and from the electron
transport chain quite a lot of ATP can
be generated in that situation it would
be a futile attempt to run the
glycolytic pathway in that situation
what happens is acetyl co a and site
read both inhibit the
phosphofructokinase and pyruvate kinase
and thereby preventing the glycolytic
pathway to flow now other than that the
fructose 6-phosphate which is an
intermediate of glycolytic pathway works
like a feed-forward activator of
phosphofructokinase so if was for
fructose 6-phosphate is there the system
already knows now we cannot channel the
flux to other pathways so we have to
challenge channel it via the forward
reaction so the freed forward direction
ensures pyruvate is generated by a
glycolytic pathway produced to 6
bisphosphate is also another activator
of this particular pathway so we pretty
much learned about all the enzymatic
controls of glycolytic pathway and how
it is allosteric how the allosteric
modulator of these enzymes are important
to regulate the glycolytic for flux and
generation of ATP which is crucial for
cellular functionality especially for
stem cells and cancer cells now apart
from all of these kind of illustrative
modulation or Atma modulation of the
enzymatic activity there could be
transcriptional control for example
hypoxia induced factor or f1 which is
actually a transcription factor which is
activated when there is hypoxic
situation or lack of oxygen this
controls 9 glycolytic enzyme out of the
pin like already consigns
impaired by regulating the process of
glycolysis so not only there is
enzymatic control there is also
transcriptional control on the pathway
of glycolysis so I hope you enjoyed this
video if you liked this video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to Like
share and subscribe and do let me know
in my comment that how do you like these
videos thank you
you